les chefs d'orchestre servent t-il à
quelque chose c'est la question que
s'est posé en 2012
alessandro d'osciller au chercheur de
l'institut de technologie tallien à
gênes la réponse est bien sûr positif
enfant on a tous joué au chef armé de sa
baguette bougeant les mains dirigeants
musiciens et chanteurs mais c'est des
gestes pas anodin alors pour nous en
rendre compte
on est parti à versailles regarder le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
a été créée en 1987 il travaille à la re
découverte et à la valorisation du
patrimoine musical français des xviie et
xviiie siècles
vous les entendez peut-être la maîtrise
est en pleine répétition avec olivier
schneebeli le directeur musical
il a accepté de me laisser diriger et
quelques minutes
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes avec
timothée la wii
quel est votre rôle vous déjà alors mon
rôle c'est à la fois de leur inculquer
ce style et c'est au moment des concerts
de faire en sorte qu'avec mes gestes
tout se passe bien justement on a tous
enfants imiter le chef de choeur et
d'orchestre
moi qui n'ai pas de formation musicale
est ce que vous pensez que je peux
diriger timothée et ben vous n'avez
jamais fait une musique pas du tout ça
va être très difficile
la seule chose c'est peut-être de le
mettre en confiance alors peut-être
juste ça alors comment fait
allez-y
[Musique]
mais après je dois lui conduire sa
phrase on leur fait essayer avec moi et
[Musique]
et
tu n'en
oh
et et voyez là je fais quelques chants
j'ai fait quelques gestes qu'ils
incitent à faire cet ornement qui est
tellement compliqué à faire qui est un
ornement qui va accentuer une note de
passage une note qui pas la note
principale
moi quand je bats ma mesure
d'accord c'est comme si j'étais dans
l'eau est si jeune âge et il ya une
presse et la pression des jeux doit
sentir la pression
alors essayez alors pouvait t il ya un
premier temps il y aurait 2 3 4
voilà parce que j'ai pris envers sa
conscience
[Musique]
où
vous m'avez mis un bon élève je pense là
bas c'est tous des balls et oui mais en
plus vous vous débrouillez pas mal pour
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais fait ça merci
olivier pour cette leçon certes courte
mais très enrichissante merci andrea
merci timothée mais de cobayes vous
l'aurez compris diriger une maîtrise ou
un orchestre
ça demande beaucoup de travail
d'expérience et de sensibilité en france
en 2016 ils n'étaient que six ans est à
diriger